مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائد او ده بالضبط
المثل اللي بينطبق دائما على اللي بيحصل
في اسواق المال وتحديدا سوء العملات
المشفره اللي هنتكلم عنه النهارده وخليني
كده اضرب لكم مسلسل رياح لنفترض في شهر
يونيو سنه 2011 واحد صاحبك جاء وقال لك بص
يا معلم في عمله افتراضيه اسمها البيتكوين
سعرها من شهرين بس كان واحد دولار دلوقت
سعرها وصل لثمانيه و20$ سمعت منه القصه دي
وعينك لمعت وعملت حسبتك سريعه لو كنت
اشتريتنا 1000 دولار من شهرين وقت ما كان
البيتكوين دولار كان زمان معايا دلوقتي
28,000 دولار فلما خلصت حسبتك في كم ثانيه
على طول قلت لصاحبك اشتري ازاي قال لك على
الطريقه رحت شارب كل مدخراتك اللي كانت
وقتها 50,000$ كويس
بتاعك في محفظه وغرقان في احلام الثراء
وشكل العربيه الجديده والبيت الجديد
والسفريات الحادثه فينها وغيرها صحيت من
امك تطمن على بيتكم وتشوف كسبه كان لقيت
الخمسين الف دولار بقوا 57,000 دولار قلت
يا ما انت كريم يا رب ما كنتش مصدق نفسك
وطائر من الفرح عدى اليوم ونمت وانت مبسوط
وصحيت تشوف ثروتك وصلت لكام وكسبت كم تاني
لقيت ال 57,000 دولار بتوعك قيمتهم اتبخرت
وبقت 17 دولار ما بقتش مصدق ان عينك
شايفاه تقفل المحفظه وتفتحها تقفل
الكمبيوتر وتفتحه تراستر الراوتر تروح
تفتح المحفظه من جهاز ثاني والرقم هو هو
مش بيتغير لحد ما صاحبك كلمك وقال لك الحق
البيتكوين سعره نهار ونزل واحد سنت
البيتكوين الواحد القصه اللي فاتت دي رغم
انها سوهايتها الا ان الواقع بيحصل فيه
اكثر من كده كمان زي ما وضحنا في سلسله
الكرتون اللي ضروري تشوفوها من هنا فسوق
العملات المشفره من اكثر الاسواق شديده
التقلب وعنيفه الحركه بشكل مفاجاه قيمه
مقيعان بفجاوات رهيبه بتحصل في ساعات
وايام دوده خلاص المثال نوفمبر 2013 سعر
البيتكوين وصل ل 1000$ بعدها ب 14 شهر
وتحديدا في يناير 2015 سعره انهار ونزل
170 دولار بس وهنروح بعيد ليه من سنه
بالضبط يعني في نوفمبر 2021 سعر البيتكوين
الواحد وصل ل
68,000$ ومن ايام بس السعر نهار وقرب من
15,000 دولار بس والتقلبات دي بالمناسبه
مش مختصره على البيتكوين لكنها بتحصل مع
باقي العملات المشفره الثانيه برده وبما
اننا دلوقت في المرحله القاع او في وقت
سوء العملات الرقميه بتعيش واحده من اسواق
او وقتها فمحتاجين نقف ونسال شويه اسئله
مهمه جدا زي مثلا لها اسعار العملات
المشفره بيحصل فيها التقلبات العنيفه دي
ومين المسؤول عنها وازاي نقدر نعرف حركه
السوء من خلال تتبع صناعه السوق الصومال
الاهم بقى ايه افضل وقت للدخول والاستثمار
في اسواق العملات رقميه وايه افضل
استراتيجيات الاستثمار في كل الاسئله دي
وغيرها هنحاول نجاوب عليها مع بعض في حلقه
النهارده باذن الله بس عايز اقول تنويه
مهمه جدا ان كلامنا هنا نوجه لمشاهدينا في
البلاد اللي قوانينها بتتيح التداول في
العملات الرقميه زي اغلب الدول الخليجيه
وقبل ما نبدا عاوز افكركم ثاني ان 50% من
اللي بيتفرجوا علينا مشتركين في القناه
لحد وقت تصوير الحلقه دي اشتراكم واحد من
اهم اسباب مساعدتنا على الاستمرار في
تقديم محتوى المخبر الاقتصادي بنفس الجوده
وتطويله دائما فباطلب من اللي لسه مشتركش
في القناه منكم انه يشترك وفعلوا جرس
التنبيهات علشان تتابعوا كل حلقه جديده ان
شاء الله تمام كده خلونا نبدا عن اشرف
ابراهيم الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
لو عاوز تستثمر في الاسهم والعملات
والمؤشرات والسندات والعملات المشفره
وغيرها شركه كابرس اللي بترع الحلقه دي
تعتبر من افضل الشركات الموجوده في السوق
وهي شركه وساطه ماليه عالميه ومرخصه من
قبل الهيئه تنظيم الخدمات الماليه في سوق
ابوظبي العالمي اي دي جي ام وعندها مجموعه
كبيره ثانيه من التراخيص على مستوى العالم
هتلاقي رابط لهم في وصف الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك بعد ما تشوفوا الحلقه ما
تنسوش تاخذوا جوله عندكم على مدار الشهور
والاسابيع اللي فاتت كنا شايفين قيمه
العملات المشفره بتنخفض بشكل كبير لا
اسباب متعلقه بظروف الاقتصاد العالمي من
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وتراجع النمو
الاقتصادي وانتهاج اغلب البنوك المركزيه
في العالم وعلى راسهم الفدراليه الامريكا
الله يهد حيله سياسه رافعه اسعار الفائده
بالاضافه للمجموعه من الضربات المؤلمه
اللي تعرض لها سوق العملات المشفره زي
مثلا انهيار تيرا لاعب عملتها لونا
وعاملتها مستقره اللي هو السيسي خلاف
التوجه الروسي يبقى حظر التداول العملات
رقميه في اوائل 2020
جديده قبل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وفي
ظل الاجواء الاقتصاديه العالميه الملبده
بالغيوم دي المستثمرين بداوا يهربوا من
الاصول عاليه المخاطر زي العملات المشفره
ويروحوا لملزات امنه شويه وبالتالي ده
انعكس على اسعار العملات الرقميه وشفنا
انخفاض مستمر على مدار سنه كامله وتحديدا
من نوفمبر 2021 لما وصل وقتها سعر العمله
الاهم والقبرص من بنى العملات الرقميه وهي
البيتكوين ال 65,000 دولار فضل السوق ينزل
بفعل العوامل اللي وضحناها من شويه لحد ما
انضرب مره واحده من ايام لما انهارت
امبراطوريه التشفير اللي اساسها حسام بنك
مان فريد وهي اف تي اكس وتحديدا بعد ما
اكبر منصه عملات رقميه في العالم وهي
باينس عرضت الاستحواذ على المنصه المتعثره
افتي اكس ولكنها انسحبت بعد 24 ساعه بس من
عرضها وده اتسب في موجات صادمه في سوق
العملات المشفره طبعا بعدها قدمت مناصره
اف تي اكس طلب افلاس والسوق انهار اكثر
بكثير من شهر ن بل 2021 ولحد الوقت انخفضت
القيمه السوقيه لجميع الاصول المشفره من
ثلاثه مليون دولار تقريبا ل 835 مليار
دولار بس في وقت تصوير الحلقه وزيها زي
العملات الورقيه اسعار العملات المشفره
بتتاثر بالعرض والطلب يعني بسبب الكارثه
بتاعك منصه اف تي اكس الجميع خاف وبدا
يطلع من السوق فالعرض زاد وبالتالي
الاسعار نازله هنا بقى في فئه ثانيه من
مستثمرين بتنتظر الكوارث اللي زي دي وتبدا
تدخل الصوت وتشترك المستثمرين المخضرمين
دول بيستخدموا استراتيجيه تستثمار قديمه
اسمها بايظه او الشراء وقت انخفاض الاسواق
وهنا ضروري نقف شويه عند الاستراتيجيه دي
لانها ممكن تجاوب لنا عن سؤال يمكن شاغل
بالناس كثير دلوقت وبيفكروا فيه وهو اذا
كان السوق واقع كده مش ده يعتبر فرصه
للاستثمار برده والشراء بقى اسعار منخفضه
هنلاقي هنا استراتي بتفسر لنا الوضع ده
يعني ايه بقى الاستراتيجيه دي كده شوفوا
يا جماعه باي ذا ديد بشكل بسيط ومختصر
معناها شراء اصل معين بعد انخفاض سعر
الفكره هنا ان المستثمرين والمتداولين
بيعتبروا انخفاض سعر الاصل ده صفقه كسبانه
لانه مش هيفضل محافظ على طول طبيعي هيجيء
وقت وتبدا قيمته ترتد وسعره يزيد بمرور
الوقت وبالتالي حالات انخفاض السوء تعتبر
فرصه مناسبه بالنسبه لهم للدخول والشارع
بسعر منخفض على امل انه يجمع ارباح لما
السوق يبدا ينتعش من جديد ولكن رغم
احتماليه تحقيق ما كسب ضخمه من خلال اتباع
الاستراتيجيه دي الا ان في مشكله واحده
بتقابل المستقبل تمارين لما يجيئوا
يطبقوها وهي تقدير الاتجاه الهبوطي
استراتيجيه مبنيه على افتراض انخفاض
الاسعار هي مجرد انحرافات مؤقته هتصحح
نفسها بمرور الوقت طب لو ما بقتش انحرفات
مؤقته هنا المشكله لان مش كل اصل سعره
منخفض بقى فرصه حلوه للشراع يعني لو
اخطاءنا في تقدير الاتجاه الهبوطي اصلا
اللي اشتريناه فضل مكمل في الهبوط مثلا
فاحنا كده هنخسر وهنضطر اننا نفضل محتفظين
بالاصل الخسران لحد ما يحصل ارتداد ثاني
لازم ناخذ بالنا من التوقيت ونقرا السوق
قراءه جيده وده مش هيحصل غير لما نكون
ملمومين بكل اللي بيحصل فيه علشان لما
ناخذ قرار يكون مبني على اساس سليم دلوقت
لو عايزين نلخص استراتيجيات بايزادات في
كلمات بسيطه فهي ان الشراء بيتم وقت ما
السوق كل يكون بيبيع مش وقت ما السوق يكون
في ذره في الشارع علشان كده لو تلاحظ معي
على الشاشه ده شرط فيه حاجتين المنحنى
الاسود اللي فوق ده بيعبر عن سعر
البيتكوين والمنحنى البرتقالي اللي تحته
بيعبر عن عدد المحافظ اللي بتحتوي على
واحد بتكون على الاقل هنلاحظ من الحركه
على المنحنيين ان كل ما حصل انهيار واسعار
البيتكوين انخفضت ارتفعت عدد المحافظ اللي
بتضم واحد يعني في ناس بتطب
وتدخل تشتري بتكوين وقت مع الاسعار بتكون
راقده في الارض زي ما احنا شايفين قدامنا
عشان كده الفتره دي بيسموها في فتره
التجميع او اكيوم العشا وبما اننا بنتكلم
عن فرص دخول السوق في اوقات تراجع الاسعار
بالشكل اللي انتم شايفينه ده فخلونا
بالمره نتكلم عن عامل ثاني باثر في
الاسعار بعيدا عن الاحداث المفاجاه اللي
بتحصل يعني بنتكلم عن الاوقات العاديه مين
بقى الجهه اللي بتسحب السوق يمين وشمال
وفقا للمصالحها علشان تحقق ربحيه من خلال
التحكم في العرض والطلب حيتان السوق او
صناع السوق بمعنى عوده ودي فعل الناس
العاديه بيدخلوا يشتروا ب 1,000 ولا ب
10,000 دولار مثلا لا الحيتان دول بيدخلوا
بملايين واوقات مليارات الدولارات بهدف
تحريك السوق وتحقيق ارباح عمل الحيتان دول
عباره عن مين برده اشرف الحتان دي ممكن
تكون صناديق استثماريه او مؤسسات ما لها
ظهر وممكن تكون شخص واحد بيدير محافظ
عملات مشفره بارقام الاخرى وفقا للتعريفات
الشائعه في السوق من الاناء ده بنقول عليه
حوت هو اللي بيمتلك ما لا يقل عن الف
البيتكوين مصر
جدا في الجزئيه الجايه دي الفكره هنا بقى
ان في سمك صغير بيقدر يحقق ارباح ضخمه من
خلال متابعه تحركات الحيتان دول عن طريق
اداه ولا لارت اللي مهمتها رصد اي تحركات
بتتم في المحافظ اللي فيها كميه ضخمه من
العملات المشفره للحجم اللي تقدر تاثر به
على الصوت فبقى من السهله توقع الا ممكن
يحصل في الاسعار بس لمجرد معرفه ان في
محفظه بتمتلك 50 مليون دولار من البيتكوين
مثلا حركت عملاتها من محفظه بارده لما نص
التداول ازاي بقى لان ده معناه بنسبه
كبيره ان الكميه دي اتحولت علشان يتم
بيعها بس خذوا بالكم من حاجه مهمه جدا جدا
هنا لما الحيتان دول بقى عارفين ان حركتهم
متراقبه وفي مستثمرين متداولين بياخذوا
قرارات استثماريه بناء على الحركه دي بقوا
بيعملوا حركه شويه يحرك كميه ضخمه
من عملتها مشفره علشان يوهم السوق انه
هيبيع مثلا فيحصل هالعلع فالناس تجريبيه
هو بقى يستنى لما السعر عند نقطه معينه
يقوم شاري فبدل مكان محول المنصه ما يعادل
3000 بيتكوين مثلا يقوم صاحبهم من المنصه
ثاني ومرجعهم المحفظه بس المره دي راجعين
3,500 بتكوين بعد ما الاسعار نزلت واشترك
ان هي ثانيه فاكرين القصه اللي حكيتها لكم
اول الحلقه بتاعه صاحبنا المشترى كل
الممتلكاته الكويت وفي الاخر خسروا كله
ايه اللي غلطه اللي عملها وخليته يخسر كل
حاجه الحقيقه انه كان غشيم شويه ودخل في
وقت الحيتان بيجمعه في مكاسبهم فبيغرس سوق
ويفضلوا يرفعوا في السعر والناس تتشد اكثر
واكثر ايه الحل بتكون وصل لكذا ده عندك
كذا هنا يدخل ويشتري ولكن قرار شراء ده
بيكون مبني على عاطفه مش دراسه وفاه عميق
الاليات السوق لاعيبه يدخل يشتري معتقد ان
الاسعار هتفضل تزيد ولكن بعد ما السوق
يحصل له تشبع والاسعار توصل لقمه معينه
تقوم الحيتان تبدا تبيع علشان يجمعوا
الارباح اللي كانوا المست اتفقنا فيحصل
انهيار السوق وهو نائم مش واخذ باله طب
حيرتني يا اشرف نعمل ايه برده نصف يا
جماعه هاقول لكم على 10 قواعد لازم تاخدوا
بالكم منهم وانتم بتدخلوا العالم ده ويا
ريت تحفظوهم وما تنسوهمش ابدا وده ثاني
لمشاهدين اللي في الدول اللي بتسمح بتداول
العملات رقميه بس القاعده الاولى استثمر
بس المبلغ اللي تقدر تتحمل خسارته يعني ما
نروحش ناخذ كل قرش معنا ونقول هنشتري بيه
او نستمر وافتكره ان في ناس حطت كل ما
تملك في عمله يو اس تي سي وفجاه العمله
نزلت لصفر وده اثر على ناس كثير بسبب
وصولا الانتحار لبعض منهم ومش لازم عمله
تنهار علشان تخسر كل شيء يكفي بس ان يحصل
اختراق يسحب ملايين الدولارات وتكون فلوسك
اه المنصه النهار ده اف تي اكس زي ما حصل
ايام دائما مبلغ اللي لو وقع منك وانت
ماشي مش هياثر على حياتك القاعده الثانيه
بقى ابعد عن العملات الجديده او اللي
بتطلع تمام وانت ماشي هتتكعبل بيقول لك
العمله دي بواحد ساند وهتبقى ب 100 دولار
ولا دي هتبقى ب300$ هتقابل من دول كثير
اول ما تشوفهم خذ بعضك واجري بعيد علشان
النوع ده من العملات بيكون معمول للنصب
وتجميع اكبر قدر من الحلوين بثراء السريع
اللي بيورطه نفسهم وفجاه فلوسهم بتبخر يلا
القاعده الثالثه ركز على العملات الرئيسيه
دائما في اختيارك خلي عينك على العملات
الرئيسيه او زي ما بتسمى طب تعمل علشان دي
عملات خدت ضربات كبيره من ساعه ما طلعت
وتحملت كثير وما زالت متماسكه فما خطرش
الاستعمار في عملات لسه مش معروف قوه
تحملها اوقات الهبوط القاعده الرابعه نوعه
استثمارك ممكن البيتكوين يكون لفت انتباهك
جدا وعاوز تحط فيه كل الفلوسك لكن اه صح
انك تنوع عملاتك علشان تتجنب اي مشاكل
محتمله في عمله استثمرت فيها كل الفلوسك
يعني نوع مثلا بين البيتكوين والايسر
كاردن وماتيك الى اخره القاعده الخامسه
احذر طمع سبب خساره ناس كثير انهم يعني
مثلا يبقى عاوز يستثمر مين دولار وياخذهم
100,000 دولار ده مش صح خلي عندك هدف
تحقيق ربح بنسبه مئويه معينه ومعقوله يعني
مثلا تكون حاطط هدف ان ال 100$ اللي
هتستثمرهم دول يكسبوا 25% فلما يوصلوا
ل125$ فانت كده حققت هدفك المعقول
والمنطقي الفكره هنا انك كده بتضمن ان
السوق مش هياخذك وينزلك بعد ما وصلت
المكسب مناسب ليك القاعده ثابته وقف خساره
من شروط الاستثمار الناجح انك تعرف انت
تخرج من الاستثمار يعني ما ينفعش مثلا
استثمر مين دولار والاقي السوق بينزل 100
وال 100 بقى 190 وانا لسه منتظر واقول
يمكن يطلع دلوقت لحد ما الاقي 100 دولار
دول بقى 20 وطلع لان ما كنتش محدد مقدار
الخساره اللي المفروض اقول عندها لا كده
كفايه ولازم اخره القاعده السابعه حد
النوع كم لازم تحدد انت ايه من اي انواع
المستثمرين يعني انت دخل تستثمر علشان
تحقق ارباح فوريه ولا دخل تستعمل للمستقبل
علشان المواعين مختلفين تماما في طريقه
وكيفيه استراتيجيه الاستثمار بتاعته لو
مستثمر وعايز ارباح فوريه فلازم تكون ملم
كل المعلومات الفنيه بتاعت التداول
وانواعه الاخيره اما لو بتستثمل للمستقبل
فدى قصه ثانيه قاعده تامه الاخبار ثم
الاخبار ما ينفعش تكون مستثمر في مجال
العملات المشفره وما تكونش مهتمه بالاخبار
لان السوق ده اكثر حاجه بتحركه هي الخبر
يعني مثلا في عملات قبل ما تنهار بيكون
سببها اخبار بدا التنتشر وتمهل لدعاء
اخبار مثلا عن المشكله فنيه في العمله او
مشكله متعلقه بالسيوله او البروتوكول
الخاص بها ساعتها هتكون جاهز ومستعد لاي
طارق وتلحق استثماراتك قبل ما تضيع
القاعده التاسعه اشتري عند الاشاعه وبيع
عند الخبر يعني مثلا لو في اشعه انتشرت
بتقول ان في عمله معينه هيتم اضافتها في
منصه تداول من المناصات الكبيره بس لسه
المعلومه لم يتم تاكدها اول لما هتلاقي
الاشعه دي ابتدات تنتشر فده وقت مناسب
للشارع اول ما يتم اثبات الاشاعه او نفيها
من مصدر رسمي سواء من العمله او المنصه
نفسها ساعتها بيع علشان هيحصل هبوط قوي
بعدها القاعده العاشره والاخيره احتفظ
بعملاتك في مكان اعمل بعد ما عرفت تخترع
عمتك صح ودرست استثمارك بشكل مضبوط جاء
وقت انك تنقل عملاتك بعيد عن المنصات
وتحتفظ بهم في مكان امن واكيد الانتهاء
سلسله الكربته اللي بداناها من فتره واللي
كنا وما زالنا بنوضح فيها بشكل بسيط خالص
عالم العملات الرقميه والبلوكشن للمبتدئين
هيعرف اننا تكلمنا عن مشاكل الاحتفاظ
بالعملات في المنصات وقد ايه مهمه انك
تحفظ بعملاتك في محافظ لا مركزيه او
محافظه بارده ثاني تقدر تشوفه حلقات
السلسله دي من هنا لحد كده انا خلصت كلام
في النهايه عندي سؤال لحضراتكم تفتكروا
وقت انهيار السوق هو افضل وقت للمستثمار
وشراء الاصول ولا البيع والتخلص منها وليه
اتابع كل الاجاباتكم في التعليقات ما
تنسوش تشوفوا الخدمات اللي بتقدمها شركه
هتلاقوا اللينك تحت الفيديو وفي النهايه
يطلع عربيتكم الحلقه دي لايك وشير للفيديو
وما تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا
واهم حاجه تحصل اصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا
يمكن يستفيد سلام
[موسيقى]